gut dann beginnen wir wieder heutigen
sitzung heute haben wir uns erstmal noch
mal diesen sehr sehr provokativen spruch
vorgenommen
von erich kästner es gibt nichts gutes
außer man tut es
und in der zusammenfassung bin ich
darauf noch ein bisschen näher
eingegangen hatten sie dazu noch fragen
die sich ihm gestellt haben
was war nochmal das problem mit diesem
satz
weil so einfach ist er ja nicht ist
schon ein bisschen als ich halte ihn für
problematisch also auf den ersten blick
ist er sehr sehr einleuchtend und so
motiviert ein so und auch vor dem
hintergrund zweier weltkriege engagement
kann man das verstehen
aber je mehr ich mich mit diesem satz
beschäftigt habe desto problematischer
halte ich ihn
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht was ist
das problem dieses satzes wenn wir jetzt
in moralische lesen moral philosophisch
als sie meinen mit absolut lässt nur das
gute tun also dass die handlung als gut
gelten
also was er exklusiv fest sie sagen
absolut ja sehr entschieden
[Musik]
gut ja genau also das war ja auch so ein
punkt den ich notiert hatte
das ist dann die frage nach der
handlungsfreiheit ne also die bekommen
dann zum thema freiheit handlungsfeld
wir sind nicht handlungs frei wenn wir
zum beispiel gefangen sind nehmen wir
anderen gefangenen in einer zelle einem
auf alcatraz sie kennt diese insel san
francisco und wenn wir da eine
einzelzelle bären im pazifik dann sieht
es mit unserer freiheit und das
verhandlungsfreiheit sehr sehr schlecht
aus wir haben vielleicht die möglichkeit
so ein bisschen zu interagieren aber wir
sind abgeschieden abgeschottet von der
übrigen welt wir haben also nicht mehr
handlungsfreiheit wir haben höchstens
noch so was wie willensfreiheit ich
erkläre es gleich noch ein bisschen mehr
also handlungsfreiheit ist die tun
können was man will tun können
ich bin jetzt auf alcatraz eingekerkert
und ich würde jetzt gerne im schönen
pazifik im sommer so wird das wetter ist
ein bisschen surfen am strand kann ich
noch so viel wollen kann es nicht tun
weil ich eingeschränkt ich bin
eingeschlossen ich komme da nicht raus
geht nicht ich kann doch so viel wollen
ich kann es nicht tun aber ich bin da
also nicht handlungs frei wie würden sie
jetzt willensfreiheit unterscheiden von
handlungsfreiheit versuchen sie das mal
ganz analog zu formulieren
ein handlungsfreiheit bedeutet tun
können was man will was bedeutet denn
willensfreiheit
genau genau wollen können was man will
aber das ist jetzt schreibe es mal hin
ist schwierig das problematisch also
wollen können was man also nach dieser
analogie müssten wir willensfreiheit so
bestimmen was ist jetzt das problem wenn
wir jetzt sagen wollen können was man
will
worin ist liegt da ein problem in dieser
auffassung von willensfreiheit da könnte
jetzt doch immer sagen das ist doch
völliger unsinn
warum könnte dass jemand sagen mit guten
gründen
genau richtig ich glaube das geht in die
richtige richtung als sie haben in sich
verschiedene begierden oder intentionen
oder triebe oder wünsche ich das beste
wünsche in sich und sie für jeden wunsch
spricht eigentlich etwas na also jetzt
in ihrem beispiel
es spricht schon was dafür jetzt in den
mathe unterricht zu gehen weil wenn ich
nicht gehe bekomme ich einen eintrag ins
klassenbuch ich bekomme vielleicht einen
wichtigen punkt nicht mit und kann der
matheklausur keine gute note schreiben
die ich gerne schreiben würde
also sie haben ihn sich wenn es um
willensfreiheit geht das ist schon mal
wichtige punkt immer so eine
zerrissenheit des willens der wille ist
gespalten jetzt das ist so eine
situation der willensfreiheit aber es
war hier noch eine meldung und der mitte
genau also man könnte sagen die
willensfreiheit betrifft jetzt erstmal
noch nicht so viel die handlung also die
willensfreiheit betrifft sie ist noch
ein bisschen tiefer see liegt vor der
handlung sie betrifft wir richtig gesagt
wurde
oder gab es noch eine meldung dazu zu
der willensfreiheit was der
problematisch sein könnte
[Musik]
gut machen wir doch mal wollen zwei
sowas wollen eins mit seinem index so
zwei stufen also ich es sehr gut dass
wir den willen unterscheiden
verschiedene stufen wir haben bestimmte
interessen
wir haben in uns erstmal verschiedene
koalitionen sattmann oder belehrungen
oder gierden oder interessen oder
wünsche
die sind motivation ahl das heißt die
könnten uns zu einer handlung bewegen
aber sie liegen erst noch vor der
handlung wünsche und ich versuche dann
wenn es um willensfreiheit geht mein
wollen so zu besteuern willens so zu
bestimmen dass der wille in einer
einheit kommt dass ich als alle meine
interessen gegeneinander abwägen
beispiel ist wie sie schon gesagt haben
dieses die frage ja jetzt eis essen so
ein wunsch oder dieses eher abstrakte
sollen zum mathe unterricht zu gehen ist
eine motivation aale struktur und ich
bin dann frei nach der willensfreiheit
wenn ich meine interessen meine willens
strömungen wenn ich die so in einem
verhältnis setzen kann so abwägen kann
dass ich hinterher der meinung bin ja
diese entscheidung mit der bin ich jetzt
zufrieden ich habe sie abgewogen ich
habe gründe dafür und dagegen abgewogen
also gründe spielt auch noch wichtiger
eine wichtige rolle gründe
was spricht denn dafür dass ich jetzt
ein eis essen was spricht dafür dass ich
in mathe unterricht gehen und dann habe
ich meinen willen selbst bestimmt ich
habe mich also willentlich auf meinen
willen bezogen will endlich auf meine
wünsche alle gründe die ich einbeziehe
betreffen den willen sind motivation
aale gründe also willensfreiheit meint
den willen bestimmen den willen frei
bestimmen zu können
den willen so zu bestimmen dass der
wille hinterher nicht mehr zerrissen ist
oder in verschiedene interessen
gespalten ist
sondern so dass sie am ende sagen können
ja hier so wie luther ist gesagt hat
hier stehe ich ich kann nicht anders
also dass sie so eine gewisse
notwendigkeit in der willensentscheidung
haben also dass sie sagen von ihrer
willens vielfalt von ihrer verschiedenen
interessen zu einer entscheidung kommen
und hinter dieser entscheidung stehen
letztendlich dann sagen so jetzt habe
ich mich entschieden ich habe alle
gründe abgewogen und jetzt kommt die
hand also willensfreiheit ist noch ein
bisschen mehr als nur handlungsfreiheit
guter punkt die leute dass sofort ein
was ich sagen nur frage ich mich dann
könnte nicht die handlung dennoch
irgendwie gut genannt werden wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel menschen helfe ganz
spannende fragen ob das noch gut ist
also genau es wäre noch nicht absehbar
sinne von anderen umständen ab jetzt
diese handlung gut ist und jetzt habe
ich mal ein anderes beispiel wenn sie
nicht noch was zu diesem kästner spruch
sagen wollen also ganz allgemein je nach
moral philosophischen kontext die nach
moral philosophische theorien
wir sprechen jetzt natürlich nur über
den moralischen begriff des es gibt ja
noch andere bedeutung von gut
je nach rahmen theorie ob wir jetzt eine
gekommen noch darauf eine die
ontologische ethik vertreten schreibt
diesen begriff auch mal hin
die ontologische die kollegen jetzt
näher zu erklären damit sie mal gehört
haben oder ob wie eine utilitaristische
ethik
ethik und moral philosophie passt jetzt
mal so im vertreten fallen unsere
bewertungen dieses satzes ganz
verschiedene aus also singt immer damit
zusammen in welchem rahmen system von
welcher grundüberzeugung wir ausgehend
einen solchen satz seien solche these
bewerten es gibt bestimmt noch andere
positionen
die werden wir auch nähe kennenlernen
also es hängt immer von der
rahmenbedingungen ab und sie hatten
jetzt schon eine kritik geäußert und ich
nehme es mal vorweg diese kritik die
geäußert haben wäre auf basis einer die
ontologische nötig formuliert nicht dass
er auf einer utilitaristischen und die
tourismus haben wir schon mal ganz kurz
angesprochen bedeutet es kommt auf den
nutzen an was ist alles bringt und ich
vermute dass sie hier jetzt eher eine
technologische position eingenommen
haben
wir kommen darauf aber noch mal näher zu
sprechen vielen dank
hat sich jeder hier nochmal eingetragen
oder nachgeprüft aber richtig drin steht
gut und so und jetzt komme ich auf ein
anderes beispiel ist ein bisschen
provokativ setzen gedankenspielen war
dafür in der philosophie an alles denken
denken ist ja jetzt nicht tun
obwohl es die frage ob denken auch eine
handlung bedeutet da müssen wir noch mal
darauf zu sprechen kommen also also im
jahr 2025 gedankenexperiment wird ein
bislang unbekanntes tagebuch von mutter
teresa entdeckt ganz zufälligen wusste
man nicht darin bekennt sie dass sie
alle ihre guten taten nur deswegen getan
hat damit sie berühmt wird diese absicht
berühmt zu werden versuchte sie immer
vor der weltöffentlichkeit verbergen
aber ihr gewissen hat sie gezwungen
ihren jetzt dass man ihr tagebuch zu
schreiben und die frage ist jetzt die
wahren mutter teresas handlungen dennoch
gut möchte jetzt einfach mal zu kurzer
diskussion stellen man kann das jetzt
nicht vielleicht nicht endgültig
klären aber waren sie gut machen sie
nicht gut ja
ja ich finde es eine ganz gute
formulierung ziemlich gut oder halb gut
nur so irgendwie
[Musik]
nicht
genau richtig weitere stimmen dazu bitte
hier
wichtig ist auch keinen unbedingt
negative absichten
also mussten muss selbst nutzen im
trance oder selbst interesse im drin
sich der moralität entgegenstehen oder
lässt sich nicht moralität so denken
dass sie zusammen gedacht wird mit
eigeninteresse oder noch einen schritt
weiter gehen muss moralität nicht auch
immer das eigeninteresse des handeln mit
einbeziehen
also eine art von konstruktiver egoismus
dass man sagt wir können gar nicht
anders motiviert werden als dass wir uns
selbst damit ins spiel bringen und im
eigenen interesse handeln interesse
loses handeln was uns selbst völlig
ausklammern geht gar nicht das ist auch
eine legitime ansicht ja
den vornamen handlung und konsequenzen
ob die voreinstellung überhaupt schlecht
sind kann man wie der kommilitone gerade
gesagt habe richtig richtig habe ich
vielleicht schon ein bisschen
vorweggenommen ein guter punkt wir
können also drei phasen unterscheiden
die handlung steht ich mache das hier
mal kurz weg die handlung steht im
zentrum
die handlung ist nicht alles wir haben
die handlung
wir haben davon ausgehen die
konsequenzen und wir haben hier noch die
motivation motivation und sie sagen
jetzt diese zwei sachen sind gut zu
nennen und das jetzt vielleicht ihr
nicht so die motivation die gründe die
eine rolle gespielt haben für die
handlung
man könnte jetzt natürlich fragen wenn
wir jetzt befragen jedoch einfach mal
die menschen die dänen mutter teresa in
diesem szenario etwas gutes getan hat
und fragen sie mal ob sie das immer noch
gut finden nachdem sie jetzt von der
motivation wissen wenn wir dieses
beispiel einfach mal konstruieren was
könnte denn jetzt ein ein mensch sagen
eine person sagen dir etwas gutes
widerfahren ist nachdem sie dieses
tagebuch gelesen hat was können wir
könnte sich jetzt denn mal vorgestellt
wie könnte sich jetzt denn da so eine
person entrüstet wie könnte jetzt was
wäre gäbe es von grund für die person zu
sagen nein jetzt empfinde ich das nicht
nur als gut
genau das wäre so ein möglicher punkte
also jetzt in diesem extremen beispiel
dass dann eine person sagt sie hat mir
da viel eigentlich gutes getan meine
krankheit wurde geheilt oder sonstige
punkte aber im nachhinein fühle ich mich
missbraucht
mutter teresa hat mich benutzt um ihren
drang nach weltruhm zu befriedigen
könnte man sagen ich war ein bloßes
objekt für die romes sucht von mutter
teresa
und deswegen leide ich jetzt oder
deswegen kann ich das nicht mehr so
sehen wie es davor gesehen habe als ich
meine das ist ja vorstellbar dass jemand
bekanntes jetzt noch weiter
radikalisieren
man könnte in dem tagebuch noch ganz
andere dinge finden die die handlungen
nun einen ganz schlechten licht
erscheinen lassen
also ich bin ja jetzt auch gespalten
weil ich habe jetzt auch keine
eindeutige antwort darauf einerseits
gibt es eben die intuition das mutter
teresa zweifelsohne menschen gutes getan
hat wenn wir den begriff gut ein
bisschen weiter fassen gut im sinne von
heilung von angenehm
wir haben ja auch diese doppeldeutigkeit
von gut wir kommen dann noch mal drauf
gut kann mindestens zwei dinge bedeuten
wir kommen noch mal drauf also in diesem
weiten sinne denke ich kann man durchaus
die handlung noch als gut gelten lassen
wenn sie jetzt krankheit und solche
physischen übel dadurch geheilt aber um
es ganz gut zu nennen so jedenfalls geht
es mir würde ich ein bisschen
zurückschrecken oder auch so was wie
heiligkeit das ist ja auch noch ein
besonderes prädikat heiligkeit also eine
person besonders hat sich besonders
ausgezeichnet auch im religiösen sinne
da würde ich also stark zurückschrecken
und selbst für seine moralischen
prädikat gut
hätte ich so meine bedenken dass jetzt
meine sowie individuelle auffassung und
jener weil ich auch er persönlich mache
ich keinen hehl draus dieser
theologischen perspektive anhänge aber
völlig offen bin und auch der meinung
bin theologie ist nicht alles und man
hat die hat auch großes problem mit der
anthologie meint einfach die ausrichtung
an einem moralischen gebot du sollst
leon ist also da die pflicht
also es ist notwendig und was für eine
pflicht ist damit gemeint eben die
moralische pflicht man könnte das in
verschiedenen variationen aus
buchstabieren das gewissen die innere
stimme oder nach kant der kategorische
imperativ als immanuel kant ist der
wichtigste vertreter aber auch bei
platon haben wir so eine art von der
ontologie wie wir heute sehen werden
damit sympathisiere ich sehr
aber das heißt jetzt nicht dass wir
richtig ist und die ideologie hat sehr
sehr große probleme
also in kontinentaleuropa muss man ein
bisschen klischeehaft zu formieren ist
die der ontologie noch recht stark in
anderen regionen der welt wird er so
eine modifizierte und die tourismus
vertreten
alles hängt auch so ein bisschen mit
ideengeschichte zusammen ob immanuel
kant in großen einfluss hatte oder nicht
mehr
ich möchte mich daher auch gar nicht
jetzt festlegen und objektiv ich
persönlich favorisiere wie die ontologie
aber es gibt sehr sehr gute gründe die
theologie zu kritisieren diese
auffassung weil sie eben tendenziell
diesen handlungs und konsequenz aspekt
zu wenig berücksichtigt
das ist ein problem der den fluten die
technologie die betrifft eigentlich nur
dass hier noch gar nicht mehr richtig
bis zur handlung das ist so die
technologische perspektive und die der
utilitarismus betrifft eher tendenziell
handlungs und konsequenz
sie merken es hängt immer auch damit
dass haben was für ein begriff des guten
wird zugrunde liegen legen wenn wir
einen besonders engen begriff des guten
zu grunde legen einen sehr moralischen
fast schon theologischen begriff des
guten dann werden wir ihre theologische
auffassung vertreten
wenn wir einen eu weiten begriff des
guten vertreten also mit auch so was wie
heilung mit angenehmer situationen
zusammenhängt dann werden wir hier sind
und wie tourismus vertreten
es hängt also ganz im wesentlich auch
davon ab was wir unter gut verstehen und
man kann mit gutem recht gut diesen
engen begriff von gut kritisieren weil
gut nicht ohne grund verschiedene
bedeutung hat und weil ein aspekt dass
wirklich guten wohl immer auch so eine
art von realisierungs moment haben muss
womit dann erich kästner wieder recht zu
geben wäre das um was damit etwas
wirklich gut genannt werden kann es auch
ein handlungsplan muss aber vielleicht
nicht so ausschließlich wie erich
kästner sagt dass nur die handlung gut
ist wenn man müsste da vielleicht so
eine synthese entwickeln das können wir
auch versuchen diesem seminar zu machen
dass man musste mit der unterlegene
utilitarismus zusammenbringen und
vielleicht eine neue theorie entwickeln
die eben immer auch so ein handlungs
moment in sich hat die aber gleichzeitig
auch die motivation gelten lässt also
die frage gibt es so eine art von
synthese aus diesen sehr prototypischen
und klischeehaft ins tal gestellten
theorien von der ökologie und tourismus
frage oder ist das zu schematisch
dargestellt aber jetzt so ungefähr ist
dass die aufteilung die esd es gibt in
der ganz große fläche und sie sehen man
kommt hier ein große probleme manche
leute könnten sich empören andere
personen könnten sagen ist mir egal
mutter teresa hatten wir so geholfen ich
bin wieder gesund geworden und sie ist
auch nur ein mensch und so könnte man
auch so aber
sie sehen es hier kommt jetzt auch so
ein bisschen die perspektive des
jähnigen ins spiel an dem gehandelt
wurde
das ist auch ein großes problem von
moral theorien vor allem von der
neonatologie bin ich jetzt
selbstkritisch dass sie eigentlich immer
nur das subjekt der handlung in den
blick nehmen und nie das objekt oder die
andere person den anderen an dem
gehandelt wird das opfer oder der der
wohltaten genießt also ich bin der
meinung eigentlich müsste die theologie
auch immer so diese objekte zeit ich
schreibe jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen
hinzufügt subjekt ebene tendenziell eher
die objektiven objekt oder der andere
[Musik]
ja die die perspektive tät würde ich
sagen ist wichtig und sie haben jetzt im
grunde genommen auf diese zwei als
bedeutung von gut hingewiesen also
einmal kann gut eben das angenehme
bedeuten
angenehm und einmal moralisch moralische
motivation ahl und sie haben jetzt diese
zwei perspektiven unterschieden wenn ich
in der situation leiden möchte ich
natürlich dass dieses physische gut
realisiert wird das mir geholfen wird in
meiner situation
und wenn ich dieses physische leiden
nicht mehr haben
dann wird mein blick frei für diese
moralische bedeutung
perspektivisch und dann werde ich das
ganze unter umständen völlig anders weil
dieses physische interesse nicht mehr
daran ist die frage die sich jetzt
braucht gestellt ist die muss der
begriff gut im philosophischen sinne
muss der muss der notwendigerweise diese
physische komponente in sich schließen
das ist die spannende frage oder oder
gelegt dass so ein ganz reinen begriff
das wäre wirklich das reine gut dass das
rein motivation ahl das rein subjektiv
also nicht jetzt im sinne des
relativismus und ss intrinsischen also
dass das innerlich subjekt innerlich
muss es nicht auch um wirklich gut
genannt werden zu können so eine
objekt seite haben ja ja ja das ist so
ich sage immer so man kann es jetzt
zuspitzen wenn sie jetzt nach besten
wissen und gewissen zum schluss gekommen
wäre
das aderlass die besten das beste mittel
ist um zu diesen guten zweck zu gelangen
dann würde ein sehr sehr radikaler der
unter logisch sagt das war dennoch gut
sie sehen das ist das problem der
gerontologie und sind nach bestem wissen
und gewissen
sie hat das nicht anders wissen genau
genommen kann das ganze auch umdrehen
nehmen wir mal so'n mittelalterlichen
mönche in seinem inneren nichts anderes
möchte als der menschheit zu helfen
er wendet sein ganzes leben dafür auf
nach bestem wissen und gewissen die
beste heilungsmethode herauszubekommen
und er ist also absolut überzeugt und
macht sich auch nichts vor nach allen
gesprächen der geführt hat dass aderlass
das heilmittel ist und quecksilber auch
noch also quecksilber und aderlass die 2
alle raten ihm dazu er preist in die
weitesten entfernten gegenden und auch
dort sagt man irgendwas und dann macht
eine praxis auf und selbstlos wie er ist
opfer der sein ganzes vermögen um die
patienten zu behandeln und einer stört
dann eben nach oben einander ohne dass
er es mit bekommen nachdem er vielleicht
gestorben ist denn während einer
technologischen sicht dieser münchen ist
jetzt genau das eingetreten
da ist jetzt anders das gegenbeispiel
zur mutter teresa da ist wirklich die
motivation nach dem theologischer sicht
ganz ganz gut aber halt die konsequenzen
total unbrauchbar
ja ja
richtig fragt doch mal alle wie es jetzt
in meinem wäre es besser nach unserem
beispiel jetzt der möglich oder die
modifizierte also die imaginierte mutter
teresa
also er ist der meinung dass der mensch
besser ist ja der begriff ist also wer
würde sagen dass dieses dieses szenario
dass da noch diese person irgendwie
besondere moralische anerkennung genießt
wer würde sagen der mensch würde sagen
mutter teresa ok also wir sehen da gibt
es immer kontroversen aber auch mit dem
münchens unbefriedigend weil er einfach
hat nichts genutzt
na da ist die touristische perspektive
die ist total raus zu streichen und als
ich als mir jetzt jedenfalls sie sehen
herz immer sehr viel mit intuitionen zu
tun wenn es um moral philosophische
fragen geht geht es immer um unsere
meinungen um diese ersten eindrücke
die sollten wir jetzt nicht
vernachlässigt also ich finde intuition
sehr wichtig also ich deswegen sage ich
jetzt auch soll ich meine intuition das
jetzt nicht mein weiß also meine
intuition ist da dass dieses beispiel
auch irgendwie nicht befriedigen also
dass ich auch im moralischen sinne ein
begriff von gut habe wo eben auch die
objekt seite der andere berücksichtigung
findet ich bin damit auch nicht ganz
zufrieden für mich geht die sache auch
nicht auf also diese starke der unter
logi ist für mich so wie ich es gerade
sie auch unbefriedigend
also ich tendiere momentan sehr stark
dazu dass wir irgendwie die zwei sachen
zusammen bringen müssen also dass im
idealfall sozusagen das modell das es
die gute handlung die ist ein spiegel
den ausdruck der inneren der innerlichen
seite sie ist nur die äußere seite der
inneren wie zwei seiten derselben
medaille
die gute handlung ist die außenseite der
guten motivation und die gute motivation
ist die innenseite der guten
das ist also ist es die gute handlung
ist ein ausdruck der expression meiner
motivation meine motivation zeigt sich
in der handlung selbst
man könnte jetzt eben auch kritisieren
und sagen dieses beispiel an mutter
teresa funktioniert deswegen nicht weil
sich motivation und handlung gar nicht
so stark auseinander reisen lassen wie
in diesem beispiel das geht gar nicht
und hätte das mutter teresa angemerkt
bei ihrem handeln dass sie dann nicht
aus guten gründen handelt
das hätte man mutter teresa ansehen
müssen das hätte uns nicht zu täuschen
können das geht gar nicht
sie hat das so authentisch getan
natürlich kann man auch schauspielern
geht natürlich auch
genau richtig das beispiel weil sie
bringen ist sehr gut weil das ein
problem ist was ich bei immanuel kant
dem radikalsten der unterlagen stellt
kann sagt wir dürfen nicht gefallen an
guten handlungen haben das wäre
unmoralisch weil dann könnte eben das
gefallen oder das angenehme der grund
der handlung sein dass wir einfach nur
handeln weil es spaß macht und was
sollen wir nicht erkannt sie sollen
handeln weil es unsere pflicht ist
ja richtig
ja wobei natürlich kennt dann doch sehr
komplex ist und eine theorie der achtung
hat kann zeigt wir sollen also die das
gefühl es darf sich ein gefühl
einstellen
nur darf das nicht so ein gefühl der
lust sein kann hat dann so bestimmte
begriffe das muss ein gefühl der
erhabenheit zahlen wenn die erhabenheit
verspüren dann sind wir darin berechtigt
anzunehmen dass die handlung wirklich
gut ist oder nicht die handlung aber
unsere motivation also wenn wir
erhabenheit verspüren dann ist die
handlung oder ist das ganze geschehen
wohl da ein gefühl mit dem spiel ist
dennoch gut erhabenheit was ist denn der
unterschied zwischen erhabenheit und
lust oder freude oder sowas so was was
jetzt erst genannt wird haben so ein
subjektives interesse
wodurch unterscheidet sich der hafen hat
von dem beispiel was jetzt gebracht
hatten dieses gefühl diese einstellung
gibt es einen phänomenalen unterschied
gut ja genau das individuum tritt zurück
könnte man sagen
aber da ist noch eine meldung also kann
sagte so kann sagt dieses gefühl der
erhabenheit das kommt dass unsere
vernunft das ist ein rationales gefühl
sagt es gibt ein gefühl das ist die
achtung das ist ein gefühl was nicht
lust bedingt ist was vernünftig ist ein
flüchtiges gefühl kann man sich fragen
ob es das überhaupt gibt kann zeigt dass
es ähnliche gefühle gibt wie die
ehrfurcht die ehrfurcht
ich denke was die kommilitonin gesagt
hat kommt schon sehr nahe gab es noch
andere meldungen hierzu dieser frage
nach dem verhältnis von lust und achtung
ehrfurcht erhabenheit also ich glaube
ist es gut was sie gesagt haben dass in
der ehrfurcht in der erhabenheit in der
achtung dass da eine gewisse distanz ist
also innere distanz da bewundere ich
etwas und das was ich bewundere ist so
idealen oder so und sie kennen alle auch
so mehr türen zu helden nein
heldengeschichten hält der sich opfert
dann macht das an seinem ideal heraus
oder eine heldin oder märtyrerin
märtyrer
das ist
ja also diese diese geistige bewunderung
als jetzt nicht diese bewunderung für
ein superstar oder so was soll also
dieses erhabenheit gefühl ich meine
erhabenheit sagt das ja schon aus da ist
eine große distanz drin
ja genau
genau richtig als ich denke diese ganzen
phänomene können sich noch mal gedanken
waren zu hause was zum phänomen haben
halt gehört aber wir haben halt es auch
er ein eher kaltes gefühl wenn man das
jetzt mal phänomenologische beschreibt
also ein trieb ist ihr etwas konkretes
also haben heute ist abstrakter
abstrakte ist es etwas kälter etwas
stiller ruhiger nicht so mitreißend sag
ich mal
und das ist einer der gründe warum
kanzler geben ist darf ein gefühls
salafismus das gefühl der erhabenheit
seine verachtung wieder mit schminken
sie sehen wir kommen hier die
speziellsten details aber sie sehen
alles hängt miteinander zusammen
ich möchte ich auch noch kurz auf diese
zwei verwendung weise von gut hinweisen
ein mal eben hier
dieses gute im sinne von angenehm und
von moralisch und einmal noch die
verwendung von gut im sinne eines
substanz oder einer subjektivierung
substantiven das gute das war das was
sie meinten so ein bisschen mit
wer ist jetzt eigentlich gut die
handlungen die person und gut klein
geschrieben also gut als prädikat nomen
prädikat und adjektiv und gut als
subjekt das als solches gut ist
da müssen wir auch unterscheiden und
wenn wir dann vom unteren reden was kann
sich gut alles beziehen
wie sehr unsere frage von vorhin auf
motivation also auf handlungs gründe
ich schreibe mir hier noch in gründe
gute gründe und nach kant auch noch
maximen das ist ganz bequem das liegt
alles im subjekt der innerlichkeit und
das ist diese handlung vorgeladen also
auf was trifft gut jetzt zutrifft gute
moralisch engeren sind jetzt noch die
motivation zu das wäre die die
ontologische perspektiven oder trifft
auf die handlung zu oder sogar nur auf
die konsequenzen die frage und dann
können wir überhaupt von einer person
sagen sie sei gut
also kann man sagen gut nicht nur für
maximen handlungen konsequenzen geben
sind auch für das objekt selbst das
subjekt diese person hin ist gut ich
habe meine probleme wieder meine
intuition jetzt ich habe probleme damit
ein menschen gut zu nehmen weil das für
mich immer so vereinnahmen
ich glaube also meine auffassung ist die
dass wir nur einzelne handlungen oder
motivation ist gründe guten in können
nicht den menschen als solchen genauso
umgedreht natürlich auch mit böse ich
bin der meinung wir sollten hier ein
mensch böse nennen sollten einzelne
handlungen oder überlegungen des
menschen böse nennen aber nicht den
menschen
er könnte sich ändern und dann wenn
wandelt er sich wenn wir sagen der
mensch ist böse der mensch ist gut hatte
sowas substantiv ist isches oder
essentiell ist in weesen stimmt wir
legen den menschen jetzt fest wir
stecken in einer schublade
und das würde bedeutende menschen zu
einem objekt zu machen unveränderlichen
objekt tendenziell und da haben wir
schon gesehen wie mutter teresa niemand
gefällt es wenn er nur als mittel zum
zweck der heiligkeit von mutter teresa
missbraucht würde also alle tendenzen
die objektivierung sind moralisch
problematisch wir müssen meiner
auffassung nach wenn wir vom guten
sprechen immer diesen subjekt charakter
dieses
individuelle nicht für gegenständliche
bewahren und das verbietet eben meinen
augen ein gebrauch von gut der sich auf
ein subjekt bezieht glaube ich nicht
dass wir sagen können
der mensch ist gut aber das ist meine
meine intuition wir können darüber
streiten wird aber auch jetzt in unseren
texten nicht so häufig vorkommen also
die frage auf was sich gut bezieht
bezieht sich in unseren texten also
betrifft mit bei unseren texten diese
frage nach der motivation und diese
frage und die frage nach dem subjekt
wird häufig außen vor gelassen ein guter
mensch dass es spielt keine rolle in der
regel die menschen was aber eine rolle
spielt ist die großschreibung von gut
das gute das gute und die substantive
hrung von gut das absolut gut
das moralische als solches an und für
sich
da spielt eine rolle ist auch
problematisch ich habe damit auch meine
probleme muss ich sagen mit der
substantive hrung von gut weil es wieder
so eine objektivierung des guten
diesmal bedeutete also nicht des objekts
das gut handelt sondern dass guten als
solche wo wir von gut sprechen im ersten
sinne wäre es angenehmer das fenster
aufzumachen sie können jederzeit auf
machen wenn es für sie dann angenehmer
ist nicht dass es ihnen hier zuständig
ich sage es nochmal sondern sie dürfen
gerne jederzeit also ich habe auch so
meine probleme damit gut zu substantiven
aber wir müssen schauen wir haben die
tendenz ist auch zu tun das gute das
böse geht das werden sehen und zwar
heute schon sie kennen sicherlich alle
diese personen hier was jemand von ihnen
wir das ist
genau der platon weil sie mal für ihn
wenn er gelebt hat ganz grob genau hier
also so 427 28 ist geboren und 348 47
also der gute mann ist sehr alt geworden
für damalige zeit damalige zeit 80 jahre
und nichtsdestotrotz hat er wurde so alt
schon ist schon so lange gewürgt hat vor
so langer zeit gewirkt hat ist platin
das wissen sie alle vielleicht der
wichtigste philosoph überhaupt viele
sagen dass viele sagen dass alle
modernere philosophie nur fußnoten zu
platon sein also lade und hätte alles
gesagt es gebe noch ein paar kleinere
bemerkungen danach aber dort finden wir
schon alles das gibt das ist eine these
eines bekannten philosophen weiß jemand
wieder heißt der diese these vertreten
hat das die ganze philosophie nur
fußnoten zu platons sagen ja whitehead
genau whitehead ein angelsächsischer
denker des späten neunzehnten und
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts der hat diese
these vertreten da gibt es jetzt gegen
theesen dazu die sagen nein nein die
ganze philosophie geschichte besteht nur
aus fußnoten zu aristoteles kann man mit
genauso gut im recht vertreten also
platon aristoteles das ist eine
geschmackssache häufig ne je nachdem
aber bleibt uns ein ganz ganz großer
jedenfalls und deswegen müssen wir mit
ihm beginnen
deswegen müssen wir mit dem anfang ich
habe jetzt ein paar leitfragen was ist
nach platon die idee des guten ich habe
ihn herum geschickt inwiefern
unterscheidet sich die idee des guten
von einer bloß vorstellung also was für
eine bedeutung hat idee wie verhält sich
die idee des guten zu den übrigen ideen
es gibt noch platter noch weitere ideen
und zwar sehr sehr viele handelt es sich
bei dem guten sehen das gute wird
substantiiert handelt es sich bei dem
guten nach platin um eine reine
moralische kategorie wie verspricht
berater nicht von einer idee des bösen
und die letzte frage welchen unter
logischen status besitzt
da ist gut also wie existiert das gut
als solches so existiert es dann nur
solche fragen wie wollen wir uns alle
heute stellen und wir lesen jetzt
gemeinsam
ich habe es ihnen herumgeschickt beim
auszüge oder bzw gar nicht aus sieger
sind insgesamt sollen gleichnis was und
seiner schrift politiker zu finden ist
ich schreibe dieses wird auch mal hin
politiker polit er heißt einfach nur der
staat oder die politik wie auch immer
der staat also dasjenige was das
verhältnis von bürgern oder mitmenschen
mitbürgern betrifft die struktur eines
idealen staates und innerhalb dieses
werkes gibt es eben auch einige
gleichnisse das sonnen gleichen ist das
höhlengleichnis und das linien gleichnis
der sind drei ganz zentrale gleichnisse
und das eine wollen wir jetzt mal lesen
wir werden auch noch das höhlengleichnis
lesen also diese ganzen fragen die wir
jetzt gestellt hatten hier zuvor
die können wir schon in etwa beantworten
wenn wir das sonnen gleichnis einmal
lesen diese zahlen danach weiß jemand
was diese zahlen bedeuten hier 507 babys
59 d
ich habe es gerade akustisch schnell
genau das ist also eine seitenanzahl
einer seiten angaben von dem henricus
stephanus es war ein französischer
gelehrter im mittelalter und der hat
platons werke patiniert der hat also
ganz willkürlich mal nicht so
willkürlich eben seitenzahlen eingeführt
damit die ganze sache objektiv
kommuniziert werden kann
und die gehen eben von a bis a b c d e
das sind praktisch jede seite hat
daneben noch unter buchstaben dass man
leichter sich dann zurechtfinden kann
auf eine jeweiligen seite und sie sehen
wenn sie das jetzt mal anschauen
natürlich hängt das immer davon ab wie
lange ist eine seite und so aber das
sind jetzt praktisch zu bisschen mehr
als zwei seiten das ist nicht so lang
ist relativ kurz aber nicht zu
unterschätzen es ist kurz aber sehr sehr
dicht und sehr sehr gehalt reicht also
wenn sie daneben darüber zum beispiel
eine hausarbeit schreiben wollen dann
müssten sie auch immer sich beziehe auf
diese stephanus paketierung dieses
seiten angaben ok gut dann können wir
eigentlich mal anfangen zu lesen
ich lese einfach mal vor es geht jetzt
um einen dialog zwischen sokrates und
dem glaukom das ist ein dialogpartner
die treffen sich dann in athen
und so kracht es ist ja diese dieser
held von platon sie wissen sokrates ist
nicht der sokrates den sokrates gibt's
gar nicht es gab ihn natürlich
historisch aber wie er wirklich war weil
es niemand platon schreibt dass eine
über ihren platten ist mit die
bedeutendste quelle von sokrates platon
hat eine sehr ideale darstellung von
sokrates er hat ihn idealisiert dann
gibt es noch einen anderen griechischen
dichter wissen sie wieder heiß die
hatten anderes sokrates bild worden
und das fällt gar nicht so
schmeichelhaft aus
genau so ein spinner einfach ich bin
verrückt
aristophanes die wolken usw gibt es noch
einen anderen xenophon xenophon hat auch
über sokrates geschrieben
irgendwo in der mitte aber die ddr
wirklich sogar das war das wissen wir
einfach nicht und platin hat ihn sehr
sehr stilisiert aber vielleicht hat ja
wirklich getroffen
das kann jetzt mal dahingestellt bleiben
wir wollen einfach mal schauen wie
platon die ganze sache jetzt darstellt
ich jetzt mal vor viele schöne sprach
ich also sokrates und vieles gute was
einzeln zu sein nehmen wir doch an und
bestimmen ist uns durch erklärung das
nehmen wir an sagte clark und dann aber
auch wieder das schöne selbst und das
gute selbst und so hat alles was wir
vorher als vieles setzten setzen wir als
eine idee eines jeden unternehmen ist
jegliches was es ist so ist es und von
jenem viele sagen mir dass es geschehen
werde aber nicht gedacht
von den ideen hingegen dass sie gedacht
werden aber nicht geschehen auf alle
weise freilich sagt glaubt wird nun an
uns womit nun an uns sehen wir das
gesehen mit dem gesicht und nun an uns
zu sehen wir das gesehene mit dem
gesicht sagt er nicht auch ebenso sprach
ich mit dem gehör das gehörte und somit
den übrigen sinnen alles wahrnehmbare
feierlich also was ist jetzt hier die
frage
das ist die bewegung nie wird jetzt hier
vorgegangen von was nimmt dieser
abschnitt seinen ausgang
und wofür diese bewegung hin
ja es geht jetzt noch nichts das serum
die das bewusstsein sondern es geht
erstmal nur also es geht um das denken
wie sie richtig sagen und es geht um das
gesehene und um das gedacht werden und
um das gesehen
sie sehen also letztendlich um das
wahrnehmbare und um das denkbar
aber wenn sie es noch mal den anfang
anschauen diese ersten vier zeilen
um was geht es da ja
genau also das ist so diese frage die
uns auch von beschäftigt hat das gute
und gut das ist gut dass es gut das ist
gut aber was ist dann das gute als
solches könnte man fragen und was
absolut gute darum geht es jetzt hier
und das absolut gut nicht vieles
verschiedenes einzelnes das gut genannt
werden kann sondern das schöne selbst
und das gute selbst ja wie kann man das
nicht dieser vorgang zu nennen wenn wir
jetzt sagen da ist was schönes das was
schönes dass es schönes wollen jetzt
aber das schöne selbst finden erklären
wie nennt man denn diese bewegung von
vielen verschiedenen schönen oder guten
jetzt hier hin zum ja so könnte man es
nennen induktion
das wäre dann so ein bisschen eine art
von also ein abschluss wäre das dann
also wir haben jetzt verschiedene fälle
betrachtet also muss es für die nächsten
fälle genauso gelten es wäre induktion
ich denke es geht in die richtige
richtung mir fehlt noch ein anderer
begriff dazu ein jahr genau es geht
beides die richtige richtung aber wie
nennt man diesen prozess von vielen
konkreten aber jetzt nicht zu einer
weiteren anzahl von weiteren vielen
konkreten der zukunft ist wäre induktion
sie nochmal ja genau das wäre
abstraktion dieser wollten sie das auch
sagen die antrieb von ihnen haben sie
ja sagen sie es sicherlich ja erkenntnis
bestimmt aber man kann sie noch weiter
bestimmt natürliches abstraktion auch
eine erkenntnis induktion ist auch eine
erkenntnis und man würde sie jeden
interessieren was für eine kenntnis
genommen also das wäre jetzt nach
unseren heutigen briefen eine
abstraktion
wir wollen nicht nur das konkrete gutes
und das gute als solches das abstrakte
gut weiß jemand von ihnen schon ob man
hier tatsächlich eine abstraktion
vornimmt
eine abstraktion also man könnte auch
jetzt sagen okay wir haben hier die
ideen und wir können auch sagen die
begriffe und jetzt abstrahiert ich mal
von allen wesentlichen was dem guten zu
eigen ist davon abstrahieren und ich
bilde den begriff des absoluten von dem
ich bei dem ich abgesehen habe von allem
unwesentlichen was an gutem hängt hätte
ich als ein begriff gebildet den begriff
des gut wäre das was glauben sie wäre
das noch platons gedanke einer idee des
guten
also ein abstrakter begriff der jetzt
gut ganz normal bezeichnet ohne diese
konkreten vergänglichen eigenschaften
die verschiedenes gutes haben könnten
das möchte ich mal so provokativen raum
stellen ich kann schon so viel sagen
nein das möchte plant nicht
sie möchten nicht mehr abstraktion in
diesem sinne betreiben wie wir sie jetzt
hier betrieben haben
[Musik]
genau also die nation ist oder woher
wollten sie sich auch noch melden war
noch eine meldung hätte ich gesehen
hatte
also richtig plattform möchte genau die
umgekehrte these vertreten platt und
sagt nicht wir haben es also die
eigentliche realität sind die konkreten
guten dingen der welt und wir
abstrahieren davon zum begriff wir
ziehen ab und dann haben wir eine
abstrakte vorstellung die mit der
wirklichkeit eigentlich nichts mehr zu
tun hat beratung ist anderer ansicht er
sagt gerade andersherum verhält es sich
die idee des guten oder die idee einer
jeden sache
die ist eigentlich viel mehr real als
die konkreten dinge die unter die idee
oder den begriff fallen weil durch die
idee durch den begriff wie die dinge ja
erst erkennen können diese idee die
begibt das wesen der konkreten sache an
also die konkrete sache verdammt ihr wie
sind diese idee deswegen musste idee
viel viel wie gesagt ontologische
science mäßig übergeordnet das seien bei
die idee des guten werden wir noch sehen
dass wir da nur sehr sehr problematisch
von einer und theologie oder einer
science weise sprechen können bei platon
die wir noch sehen werden sagen wird
dass das gute gar nicht eigentlich sein
ist oder über dem sein denn noch mal
steht wie genau das zu verstehen das
wollen wir auch noch heute versuchen zu
erklären also das ist der gedanke platte
möchte zum absoluten guten schreiben und
das habe ich schon ein bisschen
vorweggenommen dieses absolute gutes
soll nicht nur so ein abstrakter begriff
des guten sein sondern soll vielmehr sei
es geht zweite hast du auch wohl den
bildner der sinne beachtet wie er das
vermögen des sehens und gesehen werden
es bei weitem am köstlichsten gebildet
hat nicht eben sagt er glaubt also
betrachtet so bedürfen wohl das gehör
und die stimme noch ein anderes wesen
damit jenes höhere und dieses gehört
werde so dass wenn dieses dritte nicht
da ist jenes nicht hören kann und dieses
nicht gehört und diese nicht gehört
werden keines sagt er und ich glaube
sprach ich das auch die meisten anderen
um nicht zu sagen alle gleich nichts
bedürfen oder weißt du von einem an
weißt du ein anzuführen ich keinen sagt
er aber das gesicht und das sichtbare
merkst du nicht dass die einen solchen
dass die eines solchen begriffen wie so
wenn auch in den augen gesicht ist und
wer sie hat versucht es zu gebrauchen
und wenn auch farbe für sie da ist so
weißt du wohl wenn nicht ein drittes
wesen hinzu kommt welches eigens hierzu
da ist seiner natur nach dass dann das
gesicht doch nicht sehen wird und die
farben werden unsichtbar bleiben
welches ist denn dieses was du meinst
fragt er was du sprach ich das licht
nennst du hast recht sagte ja und es ist
ein bisschen sehr sehr verschachtelt
formuliert haben sie darin irgendwie
einen sinn entdecken können worum geht's
immer wieder blick auf diese gleichen es
eben das ist ein gleichnis sondern
gleich muss nun also immer eine
bildebene und eine abstrakte
theoretischer ebene werden vergleichend
ein verhältnis gebracht
und was geht es jetzt hier was es mit
dem gesicht was braucht das gesicht die
augen
dieses dritte wiesen das ist hier im
untersten abschnitt und ein drittes wir
sind zukommt
genau die sonne und das licht genau also
was ist der gedanke was ist dieses
dritte wesen ja
genau das ist gut also dieses dritte das
gehör und das zuhören
das gehörte das subjekt und das objekt
die brauchen noch etwas drittes damit
eine beziehung hergestellt werden kann
und dieses vermittelte ist eben das
licht oder dieser das licht stammt von
der sonne gehen weiter als es sind durch
eine nicht geringe sache der sinn des
gesichts und das vermögen des gesehen
werdens mit einem köstlichen bande als
die anderen solchen verknüpfungen
aneinander gebunden wenn doch das licht
nichts und es ist weit gefehlt wohl dass
das sein sollte und von welchem unter
den göttern des himmels sowohl das
dieses abhänge dessen licht mache dass
unser gesicht auf das schönste sieht und
dass das sichtbare gesehen wird den
selbigen sagte er wenn auch du und
jedermann denn offenbar fragst du doch
nach der sonne hält sich nur das gesicht
zu diesem gott wie das gesicht ist nicht
die sonne wieder selbst noch auch das wo
er sich befindet und was wir augen
nennen freilich nicht hier kommt jetzt
die sonne zum ersten mal ins spiel
was ist jetzt die aufgabe der sonne wenn
sie das ich das nochmal anschauen
mit blick auf das gesicht also gesicht
sind die augen letztendlich gemeinschaft
genau
und wir dürfen ihm nicht jetzt die augen
mit der sonne verwechseln
das ist das ist david der die die pointe
sozusagen hier hier hinten das gesicht
ist nicht die sonne weder er selbst noch
auch das worin er sich befindet und was
wir angenehmen also gesicht könnte man
auch sagen der ce sinn oder das vermögen
zu sehen das sehvermögen
ok also die potenz oder das was uns das
sehen ermöglicht ist im endeffekt nicht
das auge das ist auch so eine platte
sondern etwas drittes dasjenige was
licht spendet um zu vermitteln zwischen
subjekt und objekt geben einfach mal
weiter aber das sonnen ähnlichsten denke
ich ist doch unter allen werkzeugen der
wahrnehmung ist es doch unter allen
werkzeugen der wann also wir haben hier
verschiedene wahrnehmungsweisen wir
haben unseren geruchssinn wir haben
unseren geschmack sind wir haben unseren
gehörsinn und jetzt sagt eben so hat es
der platonische sokratis das sollen
ähnlichsten wieder so ein gleichnis von
allen wahrnehmungs organen könnte man
sagen ist das auge bei weitem also
zustimmung und auch das vermögen welches
ist hat besitzt ist doch als einen von
jenem gott ihm mitgeteilten ausfluss
das ist jetzt eine ganz interessante
these weil das schon ein verweis zu
diesem neue platten ismus ist diese
emulation jährige haben sie vielleicht
schon mal gehört das ist diese aus
schließungs aus strömungslehre ist also
das eine das absolute sich letztendlich
ausstrahlt und alle anderen unteren
schicht mindl
das kommt jetzt zum ersten mal ist mir
noch gar nicht aufgefallen allerdings so
auch die sonne ist nicht das gesicht
aber als die ursache davon wird sie von
eben demselben gesehen
so ist es sprache und eben diese nun
sprach ich sage nur dass ich verstehe
unter jedem sprössling des guten welchen
das gute nach der ähnlichkeit mit sich
gezeigt hat
so dass wie jenen selbst in dem gebiet
des denkbaren zudem denken und dem
gedachten sich verhält so diese in dem
des sichtbaren zu dem gesicht und dem
gesehenen wie sagt er zeigen mir dass
noch genauer wir haben jetzt die
gleichen ebene aufgeworfen
also hier wie es ist so wie das ist die
gleiche ebene können sie diese gleichen
ist eben noch ein bisschen noch mal mit
eigenen worten darstellen
das ist jetzt das gleichnis dass ein
bisschen schwierig formuliert
[Musik]
richtig auch wenn wir jetzt natürlich
vom guten grad noch gar nicht die rede
ist das ist jetzt oder ist das gute doch
gut genau sprössling des guten jahr gut
genau könnte man schon sagen wichtig ist
jetzt gerade auch entgangene sprössling
des guten genau also völlig richtig die
sonne wird mit dem guten wie sie richtig
sagen in einem verhältnis gebracht und
unterschieden von dem konkreten schönen
oder guten in der welt und dem konkreten
waren in der welt das ist die gleiche
ebene also sonne und das gute verhalten
sich ganz ähnlich blick auf das erkennen
von dingen und das denken von dingen und
das dem das sichtbare dass durch den
gesichts den wahrnehmbar
wir lesen einfach mal weiter die augen
sprach ich weiß du wohl wenn sie einer
nicht auf solche dinge richtet auf deren
oberfläche der tageslicht fällt sein auf
die nächtlichen schimmer da sind sie
blöde und scheinen beinahe blind als ob
keine reine sehkraft in ihren wäre ganz
rechts sagt er
wenn aber denke ich auf das was die
sonne bescheint dann sehen sie deutlich
und es zeigt sich dass in eben diesen
augen die sehkraft wohnt freilich ebenso
nun betrachtet dasselbe auch an der
seele wenn sie sich auf das heftet woran
wahrheit und das seien die glänzt zu
bemerkt und erkennt sie es und es zeigt
sich dass sie vernunft hat wenn aber
auch dass mit finsternis gemischte das
entstehende und vergehen zu meint sie
nur und ihr gesicht verdunkelt sich so
dass sie ihre vorstellungen bald sobald
so herum wirft und wiederum aussieht als
ob sie keine vernunft hätte das tut sie
freilich sagt klauke
das ist jetzt die ganze analogie können
sie die noch ein bisschen mit eigenen
worten ihre geben
also jetzt geht es um die ziele bis die
seele die erkennt
also es geht letztendlich hier um diese
diesen abschnitt ebenso um das ist
wieder die gleichen es eben ebenso sowie
analog dazu da war glaube ich die
meldung hier nicht bitte
genau sie haben jetzt auch schon
metaphorisch gesprochen wenn die idee
des guten sie einen strahlend das ist
metaphorisch also schleichendes musik
und wie der kommilitone richtig gesagt
hat wohin es geht um das verhältnis von
subjekt objekt also das was erkennt und
das was erkannt wird wir brauchen um
diese erkenntnis beziehung herstellen zu
können etwas drittes und das ist jetzt
hier bezogen auf die seele die
erkenntnis sehen und nicht die
wahrnehmen das ziel es gibt ja noch die
wahrnehmen de chile die seele die sieht
das vermögen was sieht das noch die
sonne aber das denkende seelische
vermögen braucht die idee des guten und
die idee des guten verhält sich
irgendwie sowie die sonne
das ist die pointe dieses gleichnisses
hat das gute als solches ist in einer
analogie stehend zur sonne
sie wissen ja auch in der antike oder
schon davor die sonne hat immer eine
ganz wichtige bedeutung gehabt was
könnten denn die gründe seien für antike
kulturen die soll der sonne so eine
große bedeutung zuzugestehen überlegen
sie mal was für gründe hätte könnte
könnte es gegeben haben dass bestimmte
kulturen die sonne an gebetet haben oder
einen sonnengott oder sowas angenommen
haben
genau die sonne spendet energie die
sonne orientiert uns orient okzident
o'leary also aufgehen osten geht die
sonne auf im westen geht sie unter
sie stiftet orientierung also kognitiv
durchaus gibt uns orientierung in der
welt in der zeit sie lässt unsere
pflanzen gedeihen sie spendet licht fürs
photosynthese und was ist noch so ein
moment der sonne denken sie mal an
ikarus an ikarus was ist noch so ein
problem der sonne oder wenn wir ihr zu
nahe kommen vielleicht besser gesagt ne
also wenn wir so werden wollen wie sie
oder uns dazu hoch hinaus wagen dann
bekommt das uns nicht gut und sie hat
auch immer etwas um verfügbares könnte
man sagen und auch eine gefährliche
seite durchaus ist genau das ist diese
das ist eben diese antike gut diesen
viele antike kulturen haben die sonne
eben auch als gott gesehen sondern gott
es hat durchaus etwas absolutes also man
muss sich dazu ehrfürchtig verhalten
weil wenn wir ihr zu nahe kommen
verbrennen wir tötet sie uns ne also
diese dieser analogie gibt es in ganz
verschiedenen religionen dass wenn man
dem heiligen zu nahe kommt dass man es
nicht erträgt ohne dass es jetzt
schlecht sein sollte das hat ja wir
müssen diese distanz waren und dass wir
ganz große probleme haben dieses dieser
entität also das was auch in analogie
steht zur sonne zu erkennen oder genau
zu bestimmen
das macht uns ganz grosse
schwierigkeiten weil wenn wir es nämlich
erkennen überlegen sie doch mal was ist
das problem wenn wir jetzt diese sonne
sehen wollen bleiben aber auf dieser
gleichnis eben was ist der unterschied
zur handlung dass wir die sonne sehen
oder dass wir einen konkreten gegenstand
sehen und wahrnehmen der von der sonne
licht erhält so dass wir ihn sehen
können
genau
völlig richtig also wir können die sonne
nicht so erkennen wie ein objekt dass
wir dank der sonne erkennen können
stehen sie also die sonne ist auf einem
anderen objekt ebene als das von der
sonne angestrahlte objekt und das kann
man ganz normal physiologisch wie sie
richtig sagen beobachten wenn man in der
sonne schaut was man möglichst nicht tun
soll oder eigentlich gar nicht tun
sollen oder nur mit einer schutzbrille
wenn man das aber tut dann verliert das
auge sein licht wie man ja auch sagt und
es wird geschädigt ihre versieben
teilweise also ganz ganz gefährlich und
so haben schon viele menschen ihr
augenlicht verloren dadurch weil sie
zulange reingeschaut und das ist wichtig
diese ebene und unterscheiden die sonne
ist nicht das erkenntnis objekt sondern
sie ist könnte man sie nennen
versuchen sie mal den status der sonne
im unterschied zu dem objekt was wird
dank der sonne erkennen zu bestimmen
ich habe gesagt das ist ein objekt auf
einer anderen ebene wie kann man es denn
sein
genau völlig richtig dass erkenntnis
bringen oder die erkenntnis bedingung
die notwendige bedingung die erkenntnis
der erkenntnis rahmen könnte man sagen
das ist der rahmen innerhalb dessen erst
konkrete ergebnis möglich ist bekannt
dass nach kantiger begrifflichkeit
transzendentale also die bedingung der
möglichkeit von und die bedingung der
möglichkeit von ist natürlich kein
objekt es wäre ein fehler die sonne mit
einem konkreten gegenstand der von der
sonne angestrahlt wird zu verwechseln
das ist glaube ich eine sehr wichtige
unterscheidung und genauso verhält es
sich jetzt in dieser analogie auch zum
denkbaren also nicht mehr zur sonne
sondern zu idee des guten
wie wir verschiedene ideen haben
müsste man eigentlich sagen verschiedene
ideen haben so verhält sich die idee des
guten
wie die sonne zu dem erkennbaren dingen
so die idee des guten zu den ideen also
ganz ganz spannende frage jetzt also die
idee des guten ist eigentlich nur
irgendeine idee eine idee jetzt von
bestimmten dingen oder ein bestimmter
begriff sondern sie steht noch einmal
über allen anderen idee platin ist der
überzeugung dass die idee des baumes
also definition des baumes warum hat
eine solche struktur dass die idee des
baumes sein da ist also mehr realität
besitzt als ein konkreter baum was
könnte der grund dafür sein dass
bedeutung sagt die idee des baumes ist
unlogisch also science mäßig gesprochen
wirklich oder reale als ein konkreter
baum
[Musik]
das ist richtig aber nochmal zu der
frage konkret warum wäre jetzt verplant
die idee des baumes realer als ein
konkreter baum wir würden doch sagen das
was eigentliche realität hat ist der
konkrete baum da draußen den ich
erfüllen kann den ich sie nicht
wahrnehmen kann und die idee des baumes
währende bloße abstraktion bloßer
begriff der als solches keine realität
und was könnte ein grund dafür sein dass
eben die idee sein da ist als der
konkrete baum
genau es geht in die völlig richtige
richtung und zwar ganz hinten und
meldung ja genau
also räume entstehen und vergehen dieser
baum hier wird in fünf jahren
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr existieren
dennoch gibt es bäume die an
und selbst wenn es keine bäume mehr
geben sollte wäre die idee des baumes
durchaus noch denkbar
sie ist einfach zeitlich völlig
unbedingt was wäre noch einen grund der
idee noch einen höheren status zu
sprechen
eine gute frage
wir kommen noch drauf also es gibt da
noch eine stelle die wir gleich
nachlesen werden wo es so eine gewisse
analogie gibt das mit dem guten uns
nicht richtig nähern können kommen wir
gleich noch drauf zwar ganz hinten ohne
meldung
es gebe gar keine bäume irgendwie als
zumindest hätten wir keine wahrnehmung
der erkenntnis vom baum weil uns die
konzeptuellen konzeptionellen
begrifflichen rahmenbedingungen fehlen
würden dieses konkrete objekte als baum
zu sehen wir würden das vielleicht als
etwas anderes sehen aber nicht als das
war vielleicht natürlich kann man sich
jetzt vor allem aber gäbe es da nicht
doch den baum irgendwie szene ist ein
großer idealismus darum spiel können wir
sie man kann seine physikalisch ist das
natürlich ein baum gut aber auch die
physik oder biologie brauchten begriff
natürlich also gibt es die objekte in
der welt wirklich auch wenn wir keine
begriffe dafür ist eine ganz ganz
spannende frage die blase und ist sie
ein idealist dem sitter sagt die
begriffe denen kommt eigentlich realität
zu und alles an der welt konkrete
vergeht und entsteht ist einem wandel
unterworfen
die griechen die antiken griechen waren
überzeugung nur das ist wirklich sein
was keinem wand unterliegt was absolut
ewig zeitlos konstant existiert
also sie haben auf einen guten punkt
hingewiesen nehme ich jetzt mal nur auf
diese app ist theologischer
erkenntnistheoretische leser haben also
wir haben bis jetzt sehr viele wie soll
ich sagen sehr viele anhaltspunkte
dieses soll gleichnis als ein
erkenntnistheorie zu lesen der sonne
verdanken wir unser vermögen die dinge
wahrzunehmen wahrnehmung ist eine
erkenntnistheoretischen leistung und
genauso könnte man sagen die idee des
guten verdanken wir es begriffliches
denken zu haben oder zu denken über hleb
ist technologisch das ist aber nur eine
seite dieses platonischen sonnen
gleichnisses blatter denkt in seinem
gleichnis wie wir noch genauer gleich
sehen werden und theologie also die
lehre nach dem was existiert und die
erkenntnistheorie die msc melody aufs
engste zusammen also die sonne ist nicht
nur der erkenntnis grund der konkreten
gegenständen die wir wahrnehmen sondern
sie ist auch ihr science grund als
erkenntnis grund und science grund
science grund deswegen weil die dinge
ihre existenz dass sie wachsen das
gedeihen der seine verdanken wenn es
keine sonne gibt keine photosynthese und
so auch keine dinge natürlich steine
schon klar dass pflanzen zum beispiel
nicht und genau so ist es auch mit der
idee des guten dass die idee des guten
nicht nur erkenntnis grund ist oder die
ideen grundsätzlich auch die idee des
baumes nicht nur erkenntnis grund ist
sondern
1 grund eben auch ist wir wissen
eigentlich seine ziele festlich
aussetzung werden gemacht wissen auch
sachen nachwuchs nicht
das heißt wir gehen davon aus dass das
seine dinge entscheiden sondern nicht
einhält gestern jetzt ein ok sondern
schreibt lächerlich einfach da jetzt
einen guten auch so sein wenn es gut
sind wenn jedes guten nicht ausgehen
dass das ist eine gute frage und sie
haben jetzt auch schon gleich diesen
schatten mal ins spiel gebracht
das wäre zum beispiel die möglichkeit
von hausarbeit mal zu fragen wie verhält
es sich denn bei solchen schatten
verhältnisse also um auf ihre frage
konkret zu antworten platin ist das
schon ein idealist so dass er sagen
würde wenn jetzt die sonne nicht dahin
ist oder nicht sie ist ja immer da nur
wie er selbst stehen in einem
problematischen verhältnis zu ihr weil
wir vielleicht in einer dunklen dunklen
ortschaft uns befinden dann entziehen
wir uns sozusagen im licht
also wir könnten immer wieder nach
platon zur idee des guten oder zur sonne
kontakt herstellen
es hängt immer davon ab wie wir zur
sonne stehen wir können uns natürlich
auch in so einen schattigen raum begeben
wie hier wenn wir das aber tun wenn wir
uns dem sonnen nicht entziehen und das
sehen sie selbst dann können sich ihr
plötzlich die ganze details nicht mehr
so gut wahrnehmen das natürlich schon
viel besser hier ja aber andere dinge
die sich um sich herum eigenen nicht
mehr so sehr als wir entziehen uns dem
sonnenlicht gut es gibt auch
sonnenfinsternis ist ein spezialfall
aber auch eine ja genau aber eine
sonnenfinsternis weihnachten ist halt
auch noch eine abwendung von der sonne
aber nicht die sonne wendet sich
absolvieren oder der erdball man wir
könnten ja auch um der nacht zu entgehen
in ein flugzeug steigen und eben immer
weiter nach westen fliegen ja also
praktisch gegen die erträge nur nach
westen wo immer tag essen
also damit meine ich platten ist jetzt
nicht der meinung dass wenn es jetzt
macht ist dass dann alle erkenntnis
relation nicht mehr geld sondern da ist
eben ein entzug der stattfindet von der
sonne
die sonne ist immer absolut existent und
genauso die des guten
ja aber sie haben uns wichtige fragen
aufgeworfen nämlich die nach dem
schatten nach der dunkelheit und die
frage nach der ontologie wir haben
eigentlich vor allem es theologisch
erkenntnistheoretische anhaltspunkte
jetzt gehabt und jetzt kommt noch mal an
erkenntnistheoretische zug hier ist noch
weiter dieses also was die erkennbaren
wahrheit mitteilt und dem erkennen denn
das vermögen her gibt sage sei die idee
des guten aber wie sie der erkenntnis
und der wahrheit als wenig erkannt wird
ursache zwei ist so wirst du doch so
schön auch diese beide sind eine
kenntnis und wahrheit doch nur wenn du
dir jenes als ein anderes und noch
schöneres als beide längst richtig dem
erkenntnis aber und wahrheit sowie dort
licht und gesicht für sonnen artig zu
halten zwar recht war für die sonne
selbst aber nicht recht so ist auch hier
diese beiden für gutartig zu halten zwar
recht für das gute selbst arbeit gleich
viel welches von beiden an sie sehen
nicht rechts sondern noch höher ist die
beschaffenheit des guten zu schätzen
eine überschwängliche schönheit sagt er
verkündet du könntest du wenn es
erkenntnis und wahrheit hervorbringt
selbst aber noch über diesen steht an
schönheit verlust also hältst du es doch
gewiss nicht frevel nicht sprachlich
sondern betrachte sein ebenbild noch
weiter so wie die sonne denke ich dass
zusagen verleihe dem sichtbaren nicht
nur das vermögen gesehen zu werden und
jetzt kommt's und logisch dimension
sondern auch das werden und wachstum und
nahrung und achtet sie selbst nicht dass
werden
ist bis sollte sie das sein also sie
haben zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass
wir eigentlich erst nur die systemische
dimension hatten aber jetzt hier in
diesen letzten drei zeilen hier ist ganz
klar nicht nur das vermögen gesehen zu
werden das ist die apps theologie
erkenntnistheorie sind auch das werden
und wachstum das die unter loki
das seien die existenz genauso verhält
es sich auch mit der idee des kunden
das ist letztendlich ein science grund
ist nicht nur ein erkenntnis grund nach
ist enz grund
ja genau richtig und die man physiker
würden sagen das sind halt besonders
besondere atome oder irgendwelche
strings die da schwingen bestimmten
frequenz ja ja ist ein guter punkt ich
mein weiterer punkt ist hier auch er
nimmt hier nur bezug auf lebendiges war
wachsen und gedeihen steine wachsen
nicht jetzt mehr auf der sonnen ebene
betroffen getroffen ich meine würden
haltung was ganz anderen sprechen als er
ist auf seiner lebensweltlichen ebene
ist auf seiner alltagsebene platt und
vollzieht sich alles im alter die ganze
gespräche diesen dialog den wir gerade
hier zu hören bekommen den hat plattform
so angelegt dass er nicht in einem
elfenbeinturm gehalten wurde soll auf
dem marktplatz in athen die agora also
wo halt jeder freie bürger herumlief und
sogar das spricht halt jeden beliebigen
an und kommt mit ihm eine diskussion und
nachher wird er so ein riesen buch
draußen
deswegen glaube ich dass platt oder sehr
lebensweltlich denkt als geplant muss
auch alles sinnvoll sein
er würde sagen so eine physikalische
beschreibung von steinen ist nicht mehr
verständlich oder nicht mehr sinnvoll
wenn wir kommen dann die quantenebene
usw darunter das ist nicht mehr
verständlich also erst auf dieser sinn
eben
es muss alles bedeutung haben können das
muss intelligent sein
das ist natürlich auch eine
voraussetzung man kann natürlich jetzt
in frage stellen ob wir steine wirklich
richtig erkennen auf der lebensweltliche
neben aber ein physiker würde dann eben
auch nicht mehr von diesem stein redens
er würde von dem anderer anderen
struktur reden von einer akkumulation
von eigentlichen atomen oder von energie
zu stellen oder so dann würde der stein
keine rolle mehr spielen sei diese
lebensweltliche sind ebene auf der sich
bei platon alles abspielt jetzt lese ich
gerade noch mal eins weiter ebenso nun
sage auch dass dem erkennbaren nicht nur
das erkannt werden jetzt kommt für einen
guten komme sondern auch das
und wesen habe es von ihm der doch das
gute selbst nicht dass sein ist jetzt
kommt sondern noch über das seien an
würde und kraft heraus hinausragt da
sagte glock und sehr komisch up all das
ist ein wundervolles übertreffen
du bist eben sprach ich selbst schuld
daran indem du mich gezwungen hat sie
sagen was mir davon denkt das ist jetzt
der höhepunkt dieses sonnen gleichen ist
es an dem wir auch enden wollen aber
noch einmal ganz kurz suchen wollen zu
klären was damit gemeint ist wie
verstehen sie jetzt diesen satz von dem
guten das ist jetzt wirklich unser
bezugspunkt zur heutigen sitzung das ist
das zentrale zitat als es geht wie sie
sagt nicht nur um das erkennen dass das
gut ermöglicht dass die apps theologie
sondern auch in den science grund dass
das erkannt werden das hat auch sein
sein und wesen das die ontologie sein
und wesen von ihm und jetzt kommt das
entscheiden da doch das gute selbst
nicht dass sein ist so noch über das
seien an würden kraft hinaus können sie
das noch mal mit diesem song gleichnis
ebenso ein verhältnis bringen
die sonne und das wahrnehmbare verhält
sich so wie die des guten
zum sein
wie fern muss anders gefragt idee des
guten über das sein hinausragen
bleiben sie einfach auf dieses gleichnis
ebene
sonst noch eine meinung dazu
also wie wir wie sie bereits sagten wir
auch schon vorher festgestellt hatten
dass die sonne ist kein objekte
erkenntnis sind die sonne ist die
bedingung der möglichkeit von erkenntnis
oder von wahrnehmung genau ist und die
sonne ist der rahmen die
rahmenbedingungen innerhalb deren
überhaupt licht auf gegen stellte die
gegenstände feld so dass wir sie
wahrnehmen können und genauso ist es mit
der idee der gutes guten auch das gute
ist jetzt nichts sein des objektiv sein
dass sondern es ist der grund dafür dass
überhaupt sein das ist und sein das
erkannt werden kann dass dieselbe
analogie ebene vize wahrnimmt
entgegensteht
es ist das absolut spekulativ sste was
man sich nur denken kann das wenige was
noch über allem sein denn er sagte hier
sogar sein sagt nicht also über das sein
dass sich das sein der das eine wäre
dass einzelne existierende er sagt dass
sein also die gesamtheit da müssen wir
mal das griechische nachschauen was das
ist musik oder so ich muss man
nachschauen ich weiß nun habe es gerade
nicht parat was das griechische heer ist
also es geht nur über das sein hinaus
als etwas was an spree und theologisches
oder trans und theologisch ist und das
ist natürlich höchst spekulativ
das gute wird so absolut gedacht dass es
gar kein sei mehr ist weil das sein
überhaupt seine existenz dem guten
verdanken dass gute wird hier zu einer
art von fluchtpunkt oder letzte einheits
punkt was ja so abstrakt und so absolut
ist dass es selbst nicht mehr sein
gelernt werden kann das ist also mit die
wichtigste stelle aus der gesamten
politik die wir gelesen haben und damit
wollen wir auch enden
lesen sie sich einfach noch mal zu hause
diese weiteren folien durch ich schicke
dir auch noch machen sie auch noch mal
das höhlengleichnis da geht es dann
darum wie wir uns zu der idee des guten
hoch bewegen können
als wir da kontakt aufnehmen können und
dann wollen wir den nächsten sitzung
darüber nochmal sprechen und ansonsten
geht es dann in unserem plan weiter mit
aristoteles und seiner er also pro
totally touristischen das ist jetzt
nicht richtig zu treffen auf man das tut
lässt auf seine theologie auf seine
strebens ethik die in einer
interessanten spannung platonischen
technologie steht bis zur nächsten
sitzung